the whole reason that deirdre even ran
for mayor was to erase the rutherford
name from this town's identity
exactly it's like all these people in
charge are trying to
kill your dreams with their language
programs
and their women's shelters exactly
didn't totally follow those sounds super
important there but agreed
deirdre is a dream killer yeah oh and
let's not forget
terry did not say no outright so your
dreams not totally dead
yeah they are in like a coma
somehow that's sadder there's a lot of
brain activity though
it's hopeful it just he's gonna come
around yeah
because what you're proposing is so cool
i agree it's not just cool it's like
it's meaningful
thank you you're welcome god damn it
and how do people not realize that my
family is meaningful
you know rutherford's for entrepreneurs
congress people there's a
huge corporation in midtown manhattan
that we started like 300 years ago
you know i'm the one connecting all
those dots i'm the one telling
the whole story i am the steward of my
family's legacy that will resonate
throughout history hmm that's not
nothing jerks it's not
nothing and they are jerks mm-hmm
today's making me realize how many
people out there just
don't get it you know what hey there is
nothing
you've ever put your mind to that you
haven't accomplished
when we were kids we used a dream of
starting a museum
and by the time i had gotten two masters
and come home
you had a museum you're gonna get yours
too you just gotta keep working at it
you gotta let the universe know what you
want and that's when you get it that's
how it works
totally that's how it works for everyone
for sure all right
focus what are you gonna do well i'll
tell you what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna get this town on my side yes
you're gonna fight for my family's
legacy yes what are you gonna do
i'm gonna wait three to five years for
terry to launch a project
that he didn't totally specify okay
playing the long game that's smart
in the meantime can you help me with my
thing always
[Music]
ah